[Music]
sorry
you can't unring the bell
ringing app
apparently
hey guys pete here well the most fun
thing that we've been up to has now come
to an end today i'll be talking about
severance season 1 episode 9 the finale
of the first season and i guess we
shouldn't be surprised that this was a
cliffhanger that they would end that way
one more time but that is what happened
but there's also good news to go along
with it apple tv plus has greenlit
season two so we know that there is more
coming but we're gonna have to wait for
a while to see what happens in the
aftermath of the innies waking up
outside the office that is primarily
what happened in the finale there's a
lot of interesting stuff we got some
answers to some big questions and we got
some new ones and i'm gonna throw out a
quick spoiler warning obviously if you
haven't watched the finale of the first
season there's gonna be a ton of crazy
spoilers in this so that's your warning
and with that out of the way let's get
into it
the thing that worked for me about
severance right from the very beginning
was the idea that having a device
inserted into your brain to separate
your work and personal lives sounds
absolutely absurd but at the same time
all together possible you can have the
thoughts no one should ever do this and
some people would definitely do this in
your head at the same time just like you
can have the ideas that was as thrilling
masterfully crafted intense and
enjoyable of an episode of television
that i can imagine and i can't believe i
have to wait for maybe a year or more to
find out what happens next sharing space
inside your head the premise sets up a
lot of fascinating questions chief among
them is what kind of people would
voluntarily sign up for this procedure
throughout the first season we saw some
of the motivations for the normal people
in this process
using mark as the example he had tragedy
in his life he lost his wife and he
thought that being able to check out
eight hours a day would help him deal
with that petey appeared to be similarly
motivated the finale presented us with
some alternate motivations of course the
big twist is that helly r is really
helena egan the daughter of lumen's
current ceo jmegan the motivation there
is to create some positive pr for their
family-run corporation and this
controversial program we didn't learn
much about irv's initial motivations but
he does appear to be working towards
understanding and possibly exposing
what's happening on the severed floor so
after you get past who might get this
procedure you can move on to what
happens to the severed employees in this
new life where they never leave the
office who do they become how much of
their audi is still in there and how are
they different the revelation is that
because the any versions don't have the
same experiences and aren't in fact
driven by their audi's motivations
things can go wrong in response to her
uncomfortable transition helly ends up
siding with her co-workers and if erv
hadn't fallen in love with bert he may
have continued to be a model employee
indefinitely there might not be enough
coffee in the world for his audi to set
off that integration or whatever he was
trying to accomplish there but to recap
what happened in the episode it does
pick up right where episode 8 left off
dylan is flipping the switch and
activating the innies outside the office
in a great three-way split screen shot
you see irv helly and mark all switch
over at the same time in their different
locations initially the focus shifts to
mark and you hear that harmony is asking
him if he's all right remember his audi
was telling her that he was thinking of
quitting the job she encouraged him to
do that she's trying to continue the
conversation saying that maybe he should
talk to his sister since it's a big
decision he's somewhat disoriented but
he doesn't give away the game from his
perspective this is directly after he
followed ervin helly up in the elevator
he should be as prepared as he could be
considering the circumstances it's nice
here that you can pick up on the slight
changes that adam scott employs between
how he portrays the two different
versions of mark because of that cobell
senses something's off but she has no
reason to be suspicious
in his apartment irv wakes up to
motorhead blaring on the boom box
holding a pallet knife in his hand he
sees the painting of the elevator that
goes down to the testing floor he looks
around the room and he sees that there
are several completed versions of this
same painting sitting against the walls
heli wakes up at the gala and most
people expected that this was going to
happen after the last episode and the
first voice you hear there is familiar
it's natalie's she also senses something
might be off and even asks her how many
glasses of champagne she's had they need
her nimble and you learn that she was
talking to the board and they're really
grateful for this thing that she's doing
they run into gabby the senator's wife
devin met at the birthing center and
this is where we get the reveal of her
full name helena egan so at this point
neither of the two of them that are
around other people are acting very
natural but again there's no reason for
anyone to be suspicious of them i should
mention that there are several shots of
dylan cut throughout this entire episode
where he's stretching between the two
switches to keep them open this is not a
position that he'll be able to hold
indefinitely we understand that and it
makes for a ticking clock situation mark
wanders around he almost gives things up
by asking his sister how's our baby but
she just sort of writes it off to this
weird brother and sister banner that
we've seen them do a little later he
learns that it's his sister from two of
the guests that were at the no food
dinner party from episode one he meets
rebecca who was also there and then
tries to start a conversation with devin
but then ricken announces that the
reading is about to begin this is
something that i was really looking
forward to and i love the look on his
face when he sees that they're getting
ready to read his favorite book he's
absolutely odd whenever he sees rickon
and eventually puts it together that
this is his brother-in-law when he
dedicates the reading to his daughter
eleanor annie mark is just completely
lit up when this reading begins and
harmony leans over his shoulder so that
she can read along at the first break he
goes out to talk to rickon and tells him
how brilliant the book is he tells him
that this book opened the world up for
him and that it changed his life
naturally ricken finds this strange but
at the same time he's thrilled to learn
that mark not only read the book but
actually likes it so it feeds right into
his ego he asked if they're friends and
rickon tells him that he knows that
there's been tension between them
because he feels like he looks down on
him for doing the severance procedure
but he understands that he had to deal
with gemma's passing in his own way he
brings up seeing a picture of the four
of them together on a hike but he's
pulled away before he can show it to him
he goes again to look for his sister so
he can complete his mission tell
somebody what's going on and he gets
stopped by harmony and then as he's
getting away from her he accidentally
calls her miss cobell which leads to her
realizing that something is definitely
up devin is holding the baby who's
crying and she passes her off the cobell
so that she can go talk to mark alone it
cuts away just as he's about to reveal
that he's actually the innie version of
mark irving meets his dog radar then he
looks through his apartment where he
comes across the foot locker inside he
finds things from his father's time in
the navy and beneath that he finds a
trove of documents about lumen and
severance there's a newspaper clipping
about a severed worker suing for
information following an injury with a
headline that reads lumen needs to be
held accountable if you look closely you
can make some of the article out and it
says that the employee lost the
sensation in one of his fingers where he
could have made a full recovery if they
would have been honest with him about
what happened instead they told him to
go home and put a sav on it and now he's
suing trying to find out what really
happened there's a list of severed
employees and he finds bert's name and
address on it there's also a map he
opens that up it has addresses of known
employees marked on it and he figures
out how to get from his apartment to
where bert lives he puts on his coat
grabs his car keys and gets inside to
try to make his way over to see bert
at the gala gabby is talking about how
much having kids changes your life to
helly and she says she couldn't have
done it without a little help and she
gives her a kind of smile where it looks
like there's an inside joke between them
and then she basically confirms that
she's had the procedure when she says
that she can't believe that there's
people out there who would want to
outlaw severance her senator husband
comes over and says that the photo
display was very moving but he already
knew how he would be voting it becomes
apparent that she's part of this
campaign to help change people's mind
about the procedure and it's all part of
a bigger plan to make legislation that
would protect it he thanks her and then
he asks her to thank her father if she
sees him she does see the large photo
displays that are the centerpiece of the
gala they say helly a severed story
their pictures of her and her co-workers
in mdr and these large rotating light
cubes she pauses at one with mark on it
which reminds us of this newfound
connection they have and then she
watches an interview with her audi in
that she talks about her father and you
start to get the idea that he's probably
the current ceo james egan she's
essentially doing pr speak talking about
how lumen is a big family united under
the same values as laid out by the core
principles she starts to look
overwhelmed so she goes into the
bathroom to collect herself and then her
father is led in to talk to her he is in
fact jameegan he looks exactly like his
wax figure from the perpetuity wing and
after he compliments her on how nice she
looks he asks if she's still in pain
this makes it sound like this is the
first time they've seen each other since
the suicide attempt he says that he
cried in bed when they told him what she
did to him what that innie did to him
and there's noticeable disdain in his
voice when he says the word any he
thanks her for going through with the
procedure and tells her that the
grandfather would cherish what she's
done referring to kyr and then he adds
that one day she'll sit with him at his
revolving which i'm sure is a term that
we're going to be wondering about until
season two starts he asks if she
remembers when he brought home the first
chip to show her he refers to it as the
prototype and says that it had the blue
and green lights back then and that
makes you think about the green and blue
badges and the way that those were
reversed in the paintings of the coup he
says that he remembers that she told him
that it was so pretty and that everyone
in the whole world should get one and
now he says that they will they'll all
be keir's children natalie comes in to
interrupt them to say it's time for her
to give her speech left alone she pauses
at the mirror and she begins to recite
the compunction statement that she had
to say when she was in the break room
cobella has left a party in her car
she's driving recklessly towards the
lumen office trying to get milcheck on
the phone mark has made his confession
to devin he tells her that they need to
get inspectors to go and check out
what's happening on the severed floor
she mentions that his audi has been
trying to figure out what they do at
work and he responds that he just wants
to know why he went through with the
procedure and that leads to her
explaining that he lost his wife she
explains how he tried to go back to his
job as a professor but he wasn't able to
because she was still in his veins you
know making everything hurt just after
we see harmony pass herb going the other
way she finally gets milcheck on the
phone she tells him that the otc has
been activated and that she just saw
mark as his innie at the party she
believes that dylan is behind it and
that they were planning this all along
she tells him to get to the security
office and stop dylan he takes off
sprinting down the hall but he can't get
inside the office when he gets there
because of dylan's belt devin tells mark
that she thinks they need to be careful
about who they talk to because lumen has
their hands in so many pies she thinks
the right idea might be to contact
journalists that rickon knows while
they're talking about that he remembers
to ask her why cobell was there he
explains that that's his boss and devin
realizes that it's who she knows as mrs
selvig this freaks her out because she
knows she gave her baby to her and now
they can't find her the whole party
starts to look for her and at this point
everything is starting to come together
helly's getting ready to go on stage irv
has pulled up outside bert's house and
milcheck continues to cut through his
belt while he tries to talk dylan down
offering him new perks ones that he says
he's never even heard about like
paintball and coffee cozies and dylan
just says he wants to remember his son
being born at this milchek tells him he
has two others and promises to tell him
their names if he just opens the door
harmony does arrive at the gala she runs
inside in such a hurry that her car
rolls away in the commotion and you see
the valets chasing after it inside
natalie's preparing hallie telling her
to just stick with the talking points
use the line about how you see your
innie as your sister irving sees bert
through his front window and sees that
he's with another man it looks like
they're together and they're packing up
for a trip they do find eleanor in her
car seat in one of the bedrooms and it's
hilarious that this other guy takes the
credit for being the one who found her
on stage natalie is warming up the crowd
and she's talking about how there's been
setbacks bumps in the road but now
they're on the verge of a revolution a
kind and empathetic revolution that puts
the human being in the center of
industry at the same time cobell grabs
heli she asks is it you and helly looks
at her and says i'm going to kill your
company cobell responds your friends are
going to suffer mark will suffer you'll
be long gone but we'll keep them alive
in pain and of course this is something
that we'll be coming back to kelly's
pulled away to go on stage as she's
coming out you see mark pick up a photo
from his wedding he recognizes mrs casey
irv gets out of his car and goes up to
bert's door millcheck continues to cut
and heli introduces herself saying my
name is helly r i'm a ninny and
everything they've told you about
severance is a lie
irv continues to pound on the door
shouting bert's name mark runs out of
the room looking for devin helly
continues saying we're not happy we're
miserable they torture us down there
milcheck finally gets the door open and
charges towards dylan helly is pulled
away tackled on stage by natalie and
mark shouts to devin she's alive just as
milcheck tackles dylan causing him to
let go of the switches you see mark
switch back over to his audi and the
episode ends there and you have to hope
that they will understand that he was
talking about the picture with this
whole eleanor gone missing commotion
happening at the same time of course the
baby's alive but that's not who he was
talking about so yeah this was a
fantastic episode of television to cap
off a fantastic season they layered the
tension on top of itself and also made a
ton of references to things that
happened earlier to make it clear that
you really need to pay attention i think
there probably would have been a
backlash if they hadn't announced season
two but as things stand it's a confident
way to end things keep those big
questions out there keep us thinking
about the answers because there's a lot
of fun in that while also giving us
enough to know that it will all
eventually lead to something this is all
propped up by terrific performances by
an amazing cast snappy writing
deliberate pacing genuinely funny
moments and a strong vision in the
directing at the center of the story
you've got mark who's trying to become
something he's lost his partner and
that's left him not knowing who he is he
made what to us doesn't appear to be a
sound decision but in the end it may
lead him on the journey he needs to go
on in order to find himself the surface
level critique of the way we view work
and what we go through is enough to pull
you in and then where it really gets fun
is that the innies are basically
children they're fully formed adults
that are influenced by things the same
way as you and me but they have zero
experience shaping them as individuals
lumen is a corporation that certainly
has some cultish undertones there's
something going on with these eagans
even more so than the normal kind of
thing that happens at real corporations
all the time in our world and they're
trying to mold these people into model
employees in light of that what happened
in the finale is basically a disaster
but based on everything we've seen
there's only two real problems that they
might run into mark talking to devin and
then the spectacle of what heli said the
way the gala was set up it was intended
to put a positive spin on the severance
procedure so you would imagine they
invited some skeptical people there to
witness this thing and she did a pretty
good job of tanking that they are pretty
powerful though so you have to wonder if
they would be able to keep it quiet or
at least minimize the impact of what
happened i thought it stood out that
cobell was confident in saying that they
were going to keep the innies alive in
pain we know that audi heli wouldn't be
supportive of what her any did i don't
anticipate her changing her mind about
that and for the others my thoughts went
to these other protocols we saw like the
clean slate which makes you think
there's a good chance that they could
just wipe their memories it feels like
there's a non-zero chance that the next
time they all come together at work they
won't remember what happened it's not
easy to see where they would go from
there though a big part of what happened
in this first season is that mdr came
together and formed this bond as a team
they were able to make it out and see
the real world if they make it so that
lumen has the ability to wipe their
minds then there almost has to be a
situation where they can do that all
over again so right now i think they'll
all probably end up back there working
in mdr probably even heli and we'll see
how the experience has changed them
we'll see the backlash from lumen and
how their managers respond and get
closer to understanding all the big
mysteries in the process
i think what irv's up to became a really
interesting question during this finale
and of course we're all still wondering
what's going on with mark and gemma aka
miss casey the way that irv is drinking
coffee to keep his innate tired possibly
trying to get him to fall asleep at work
and then also repeatedly painting the
same image of the testing floor which he
really shouldn't know about certainly
makes you wonder he seems to be working
towards integrating the indian audi by
passing that information telling him to
go looking for this elevator the whole
romance with bert was one of the most
fun things to watch because of the
situation they find themselves in and it
made for a sad reveal at the end but i'm
still thinking there's more to come from
these two i'm just not sure how the way
things were left his audi is going to be
at the door when bert opens it and
perhaps since his name was on the map
they'll already know each other maybe
he's already reached out to some of
these severed employees mark just has to
go looking for gemma what's going on
with her and that testing floor is a
central mystery in conjunction with the
story of him finding himself being the
central character it all makes marx seem
special not just a harmony but possibly
to the egan's overall goal and that is
an even bigger question i suppose we're
closer to understanding and that we know
that they want to make everyone kiers
children but what exactly does that mean
waffle parties for everyone get people
to get the chip not just for work but in
the way that gabby's using it and then
flip the switch activate the cure army i
mean i guess we're gonna have to wait
and see i'll take some time and think
about it all and then i'll put out a
couple more videos i know i said i'd do
that last week but i got covered and i
still haven't really recovered yet but
there is more severance content to come
i think this is a good place to leave
this one i can't wait to hear what you
guys thought about the finale how your
ideas about the show have changed what
your theories are going into season two
so make sure you let me know all about
them in the comments please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon